les employés de la société publique
vénézuélienne de pétrole et de gaz
naturel célèbre l'arrivée de leur
sauveur
le fortuna accosté dans le port d'el
palito à près de 200 km à l'ouest de
caracas où se trouve une énorme
raffinerie à son bord des combustibles
des pièces de rechange et de nombreux
équipements destinés à renforcer la
capacité de raffinage du venezuela
présent sur place le ministre
vénézuélien du pétrole remercie le
pouvoir iranien pour son geste
merci au gouvernement et au peuple
iraniens au président rohani et à toutes
les autorités qui se sont exprimé
fermement et courageusement pour
garantir et faire avancer les accords de
coopération énergétique
existant depuis longtemps entre l'iran
et le venezuela le fortune n'est que le
premier des cinq pétroliers attendu au
venezuela
il devrait être suivi rapidement par
quatre autres navires similaire qui
doivent arriver dans les prochains jours
c'est à dire adn survient alors que le
venezuela en pleine crise économique
rencontre de grandes difficultés pour
extraire son pétrole bien qu'il ait les
plus grandes réserves au monde
le pays ne produit qu'environ 622 1000
barils par jour soit un cinquième du
volume extrait il ya dix ans selon
l'opep
conséquence depuis plus de deux mois une
très grave pénurie sévit dans tout le
pays malgré le confinement destiné à
juguler l'épidémie de coronavirus de
gigantesques files d'attentes de
véhicules c'est hier devant les stations
service les premiers jours c'était
difficile mais dernièrement j'ai pu
parler au colonel en charge de la
station essence en lui expliquant mon
cas et j'ai été capable de prendre de
l'essence deux fois en une semaine
je voulais dit j'ai eu de la chance
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
attendent encore et c'est impossible
pour l'heure de faire le plein d'essence
sur le marché noir le litre de carburant
se vend jusqu'à 3 dollars
un prix astronomiques dans un pays où le
salaire minimum équivaut à quelques
dollars par mois
les livraisons de carburants de l'iran
au venezuela interviennent dans un
contexte toujours tendu entre les états
unis et les deux pays
washington cherche notamment empêché les
exportations iraniennes de brut au
venezuela et a reconnu en 2019 comme
président par intérim
le chef de l'opposition vénézuélienne
juan garrido au total ces cinq
pétroliers a envoyé par l'iran doit
fournir au venezuela au million et demi
de barils